je suis un peu embêté par la première
question pourquoi puisque la phrase que
vous citez figurez vous que je la
connais puisque c'est une phrase qui est
sorti de ma bouche en garde à vue donc
ça de phrases là c'est une fuite de mes
déclarations en garde à vue dans la
presse et je les dis je ne commenterai
pas les propos que j'ai moi-même tenue
civile et si je commence à commenter le
propos que j'ai moi-même tenue qui est
un commentaire du propos que j'ai moi
même tenu il ya trois jours on s'en
sortira pas
donc ce que je pourrais vous dire par
contre c'est que monsieur ben alla et
c'est normal puisqu'il et travaille à la
chefferie de cabinet qu'il est adjoint
au chef de cabinet sur un déplacement du
président de la république il ya un
télégramme de la direction de l'ordre
public et de la circulation
il ya des plans qui sont parfois des
plans complexes qui sont des plans
importante puisqu'il ya des mesures en
termes de circulation
on peut prendre des mesures sur des
fermetures de stations de métropolitains
on peut équiper des points hauts donc ce
sont des informations qui sont
stratégiques pour le déplacement du
président de la république
ces informations là qui sont dans un
télégramme de services et qui sont dans
une cartographie il est normal que les
services de la présidence y aient accès
nous travaillons sur le même service
imaginez vous que je ne parte que la
démo pc ne partage pas ces informations
avec la chefferie de cabinet qui est
chargé de donner le rythme du
déplacement du président de la
république
donc c'est normal que monsieur mannala
sur les déplacements du président de la
république au cours desquelles ils
exercer la fonction d'adjoint au chef de
cabinet du président de la république
soit destinataire des télégrammes de ses
services d'ordre ça c'est pour la
première question mais sur le co
rapporteur pour la deuxième question est
ce que j'ai été témoin d' instructions
données directement entre monsieur
benalla et des fonctionnaires sur les
déplacements une place de la république
quand je suis présent tant qu autorité
civile sur un déplacement du président
de la république je suis commissaire de
police donc sophie un autre commissaire
de police qui étaient également présents
et qui est d'un niveau hiérarchique
supérieur
je représente la démo pc et donc j'ai en
charge les fonctionnaires de police delà
des opc donc si je suis présent et qu'il
ya une demande de la chefferie de
cabinet elle est passée un fonctionnaire
ce fonctionnaire là
la sphère inventé moi je n'ai pas été
témoin je n'ai pas été témoin sur la
dizaine de service d'ordre du président
de la république que j'ai réalisé et au
monsieur ban a été présent en tant
qu'adjoint au chef de clinique je n'ai
pas été témoin d' instruction passer
directement entre monsieur mannala et
impersonnel mais il faut également le
dire il faut également le dire parfois
les déplacements du président de la
république peuvent être un petit peu
sensible on peut avoir des troubles à
l'ordre public on peut avoir des gens
qui sont là pour manifester leur
désaccord par rapport au président de la
république donc parfois la différence
entre une instruction et une demande ça
pète le ton qui est employé dans la voix
personne n'a dessus fait tout le monde
là dessus on est d'accord quand il une
situation stressante canton une
situation qui est un petit peu difficile
on peut un petit peu avoir des propos un
petit peu direct je vous le redis
l'autorité mon autorité à la préfecture
de police c'est le préfet de police de
paris
mais ce banal à oumé se loge en tant
qu'adjoint ou en tant que chef du
cabinet du président de la république
représente une autorité et donc quand
ils expriment une demande on se met en
mesure d'exécuter cette demande selon le
schéma que je vous ai précisé c'est à
dire je fais remonter cette demande à la
salle d'information et de commandement
puis cette demande est validée et
redescend voilà j'espère avoir été
extrêmement clairs sur les instructions
directes sur la question des
instructions directes